So just to give you a quick example of those view modes,
when we're inside of Unreal,
so you can see by default we've opened in lit mode.
So we can see we've got shadowing going on,
we've got the global illumination system working.
So we're in lit mode right now.
So let's go to unlit and see that.
So because there's no other materials on these walls,
it's very hard to see any definition
because a lot of the definition
was being caused by the lighting.
But if I pan around, you can see the different material
that might be being used
and essentially it's color and textures only.
And then we could see lighting only for example.
So we can only see lighting information.
So now we can't see any of the coloring on the textures,
but we can see the shadowing that's happening
with the lighting and we might just care about
how the light is impacting the scene.
And then we could also go to detail lighting
just to see that extra view mode there.
So again, there's a lot of view modes to play with
depending on the work that you're currently doing.
You might find some more useful than others,
but that's just to give you a quick explanation
of what's happening inside of Unreal.